he is this week's gorilla glue toughest
player on planet earth from the oklahoma
sooners
please welcome dj graham here on the
rich island show yes
yes how are you dj
i'm doing great how y'all doing i'm
doing fine yeah you're doing great
uh congratulations on on winning this
award and holding down the uh the
secondary along with your teammates for
oklahoma obviously
part of what put you on our radar screen
was that one-handed interception that
you came up with this past week
uh did you see trey young got that on
his insta he put it on his gram did you
see that dj no i i did uh matter of fact
even even before the game during
warm-ups
i'm like who is this who was this dude
in this malcolm kelly jr i didn't even
i was like wait a minute i thought the
big change i'm like okay it's got to be
somebody big time but
no i
yeah i had like of course i thought it
was everywhere like trey young's view
and i saw trey young's reaction which
was this was priceless but
no it was it was really cool it has to
be really cool who else did you hear
from after coming up with what people
are saying is the
interception
of the year in college football or in
football periods ou legends um
adrian peterson
um cb lamb
kenneth murray
kenny stills aaron colvin just
dudes that
that are oh yeah joe makes it also like
just you know oh you legends and it's so
it is so weird to
to be in the limelight like that
especially amongst like you know players
like that and recent players also people
players that i that i grew up watching
and players that
you know that made such a big impact
odell has have you heard from becca yes
oh my goodness my idol odell was oh that
was literally
that was literally my my idol um
which was i i guess i'm probably the
most proud of that one uh sorry oh you
my own
uh alumni but sure the odell one that
just that just blew me away
did he did he send you a message or did
he dm you or do you put something on
this i'm not i'm not i'm not that big
time yet um he just you know he
mentioned me in the tweet uh you know he
said uh oh that was a heck of a grab a
heck of a pick number nine
but you know
that's fine that was enough that's all i
needed well i mean look and and it is
not easy doing what you're doing i mean
i can only imagine being a defensive
back in the big 12. you talk about being
on an island oh my gosh you are on an
island
so obviously this is a spectacular
single play but what about your your
approach to the game
you know we we've heard about you we
looked into it that's part of the reason
why we also appreciate giving this award
to you is your approach and i'd love for
you to just put that one out there
yeah um uh well
my approach being being a corner is
first of all i mean it's football um
it's division one
and you know there's there's on the
other side of the ball there's a there's
a person that is as athletic or more
athletic as you and it's just football
and football players are going to happen
um so you have to accept that part that
okay you're not going to be perfect on
every rep and you're going to get beat
on some plays
and you have to have a short memory um
as a corner my coach my coach ray
makings you always used to tell me you
can't you can't just linger you can't
keep lingering on on plagues you have to
have a short memory
put it put it put in the trash in your
mind and and it's the next rep
um and the next thing you gotta have you
gotta have technique um
everybody's good now everybody's fast
everybody's big
if you don't have any technique nobody's
beyond sanders no i mean you i don't i
don't wanna i don't want a 4-1
so world war two so i have to i had to
bring take me to the table
and um and i and then once i bring my
technique to the table my talent and my
ball skills will take care of everything
else
and um i would say the last one uh i
don't think
a football player is not a football
player without being physical i don't
think there's any any soft football
players
um i think physicality is a big part of
this is almost one of the name of the
games in football i believe if you're
physical uh you have a other edge and a
middle edge on your opponent
and um you know and corners we're not
the biggest on the field so
when we do when we do get into certain
altercations we have to bring it and we
have to bring doesn't bring all of us
you know we can't just we can just put a
shoulder in there
uh we have to bring it on okay
i love this
i love this dj graham because you know
one thing you did leave out is is you
know fundamentals and being
situationally smart so i am mandated to
say since you are a rich eisen show
gorilla glue toughest player on planet
earth you do realize that the
interception that got everybody's
attention was on fourth down you should
have batted the ball down right dj oh
yeah you're aware of that yeah yeah no
yeah situation
okay just want to make sure because i
think if i'm not mistaken lincoln riley
was thinking of challenging that hoping
you didn't not in fact grab it with your
one hand and come up with the wild play
of the year
because it cost a few yards of field
position right
dj yeah i was a little you know i was
i guess looking at it and uh when i was
on the bench and i just i had a i had a
few minutes to think like okay i did pin
him back but yeah you know see ball get
ball
see ball
and then ballers like trae young put you
on instagram accounts and then trey
young wasn't the only uh basketball
player that day i i think sean kemp was
there wait a minute no that's you
coming to the game
oh sorry
no
aren't you coming to the game and in
sean kemp gamers dj
right hey i didn't
that's what sean campbell
i'm sorry i thought that was you and a
sean kemp gamer coming to the game
that's not you oh oh no yeah it was no
no yeah that was uh that was last week
yeah i was gonna
[Music]
yeah yeah okay because i thought that
was you so what's with the sean kemp
jersey
what's with that well
well rich uh i'd break it i do have a
lot of jerseys okay um
i do have a lot i have a matter of fact
the the greatest player of all time in
basketball i had having home and away
michael jordan
uh i pretty much have okay greatest
lakers you know i have a lot of judges
so i was just thinking i was like you
know what i need to bring out a jersey
i was like you know why not uh
why not bring out the the shawn kim
jones okay well now you know what you
have dj graham
you got glue you got a whole bunch of
glue coming your way what needs fixing
what needs fixing in your life glue and
tape gorilla glue's giving you holes
bunch of stuff and of course you know
the check for a thousand bucks in your
name image and likeness deal
what do you mean what are you gonna fix
what do you need to fix with your glue
you know what i might i don't know what
i need to say i might just i don't know
i might just take something apart and uh
just test the glue out
you know
i might just do a bunch of
i might just tell my parents i might
just send this to my parents and just
tell them you know hey mom uh just go
ahead and break something there you go
you know we'll see how good let's see
how good this glue is all right well
it's good don't worry about it it's so
good it's so good people are gonna think
that you you had it on your hands last
week that's how that's how good it is
man that's how good it is yeah well dj
congratulations on on uh on everything
that's going on with you uh we're gonna
keep an eye on you throughout the season
um you're definitely flashed but you
also have what it takes to be a football
player outside the flash and that's part
of the reason why you're the toughest
player on planet earth this week thanks
for the call thanks for everything
appreciate it
you got it that's dj graham right here
the toughest player on planet earth on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here